if you zoom into anything what are you
going to see of course you're just going
to see physics what else could be
underneath right that's not going to be
fairy dust it's going to be physics and
chemistry but that doesn't take away
from the magic of the fact that there
are certain ways to arrange that physics
and chemistry and in particular the
bioelectricity which I like a lot uh to
give you an emergent uh Collective with
goals and preferences and memories and
anticipations that do not belong to any
of the subunits so I think what we're
getting into here and we can talk about
how how this happens during
embryogenesis and so on what we're
getting into is the origin of the of a
self yeah with a big with a capital S so
we ourselves there are many other kinds
of cells and we can tell some really
interesting stories about where cells
come from and how they become unified
yeah is this the first
or at least humans tend to think that
this is the the level of which the self
with the capital s is first born
but uh and we really don't want to see
um human civilization or Earth itself as
one living organism yeah that's very
uncomfortable to us it is yeah but is um
yeah where's the self born we have to
grow up past that so what I like to do
is uh I'll tell you two quick stories
about that I like to roll backwards so
so as opposed to so if you start and you
say okay here's a paramecium and you see
it um you know it's a single cell
organism you see it doing various things
and people will say okay I'm sure
there's some chemical story to be told
about how it's doing it so if that's not
true cognition right and people will
argue about that I I like to work it
backwards I say let's let's agree that
you and I uh as as we sit here are
examples of true cognition if anything
is if there's anything that's true
cognition we are we are examples of it
now let's just roll back slowly right so
you roll back to the time where you're a
small child and used to doing whatever
and then just sort of day by day you
roll you roll back and eventually you
become more or less that paramecium and
then and then you sort of even below
that right as an unfertilized Osa so
it's no one has to my knowledge no one
has come up with any convincing discreet
Step At which my cognitive Powers
disappear right it just doesn't the
biology doesn't offer any specific step
it's com it's incredibly smooth and slow
and continuous and so I think this idea
that it just sort of magically shows up
uh at one point and then and then uh you
know humans have true selves that don't
exist elsewhere I think it runs against
everything we know about Evolution
everything we know about developmental
biology these are all slow continua and
the other really important story I want
to tell is where embryos come from so
think about this for a second amniode
embryo so this is humans birds and so on
uh mammals and birds and so on imagine a
flat disc of cells so there's maybe 50
000 cells and in that so when you get an
egg from a from a fertilizer let's say
you buy a fertilized egg from a farm
right that that egg uh will will have
about 50 000 cells in um in a flat disk
it looks like a little little tiny
little Frisbee and in that flat disc
what will happen is there'll be one one
set of cells will become will become
special and it will tell all the other
cells I'm I'm going to be the head you
guys don't be the head and so it'll
amplify symmetry breaking amplification
you get one embryo there's a there's a
you know there's some neural tissue and
some other stuff forms now now you say
okay I had one egg and one embryo and
then there you go what else could it be
well the reality is and I used to I I
did all of this as a grad student if you
um if you take a little needle and you
make a scratch in that blastoderm in
that in that disc such that the cells
can't talk to each other for a while it
heals up but for a while they can't talk
to each other what will happen is that
uh both regions will decide that they
can be the embryo and there will be two
of them and then when they heal up they
become conjoint Twins and you can make
two you can make three you can make lots
so the question of how many selves are
in there cannot be answered until it's
actually played all the way through it
isn't necessarily that there's just one
there can be many so what you have is
you have this medium this this
undifferentiated I'm sure there's a
there's a psychological
um version of this somewhere that I
don't know the proper terminology but
you have this you have this list like
put ocean of potentiality you have these
thousands of cells and some number of
individuals are going to be formed out
of it usually one sometimes zero
sometimes several
and they form out of these cells because
a region of these cells organizes into a
collective that will have goals goals
that individual cells don't have for
example uh make a limb make an eye how
many eyes well exactly two so individual
cells don't know what an eye is they
don't know how many eyes you're supposed
to have but the collective does the
collective has goals and memories and
anticipations that the individual cells
don't and that that the establishment of
that boundary with its own
um ability to maintain to to pursue
certain goals that's the origin of of
selfhood
but I is that goal
in there somewhere were they always
destined like are they discovering that
goal like where the hell did Evolution
um discover this when you went from the
prokaryotes to you eukaryotic cells
and then they started making groups and
when you make a certain group you make a
you you make it sound
as such a tricky thing to try to
understand you make it sound like this
cells didn't get together and came up
with a goal but the very Act of them
getting together
revealed the goal that was always there
there was always that potential for that
goal so the first thing to say is that
there are way more questions here than
than certainties okay so everything I'm
telling you is is Cutting Edge
developing you know stuff so so it's not
as if any of us know the answer to this
but but here's here's here's my opinion
on this I think what evolution I I don't
think that Evolution produces solutions
to specific problems in other words
specific environments like here's a frog
that can live well in a froggy
environment I think what evolution
produces is problem-solving machines
that that will that will solve problems
in different spaces so not just
three-dimensional space this goes back
to what we were talking about before we
the the brain is a evolutionarily a late
development it's a system that is able
to to pursue goals in three-dimensional
Space by giving commands to muscles
where did that system come from that
system evolved from a much more ancient
evolutionarily much more ancient system
where collections of cells gave
instructions to for cell behaviors
meaning cells move to to divide to to
die to change into different cell types
to navigate morphe space the space of
anatomies the space of all possible
anatomies and before that cells were
navigating transcriptional space which
is a space of all possible Gene
expressions and before that metabolic
space so what evolution has done I think
is is is produced Hardware that is very
good at navigating different spaces
using a bag of tricks right which which
I'm sure many of them we can steal for
autonomous vehicles and Robotics and
various things and what happens is that
they navigate these spaces without a
whole lot of commitment to what the
space is in fact they don't know what
the space is right we are all brains in
a vat so to speak every cell does not
know right every cell is some other some
other cell's external environment right
so where does the that border between
you you and the outside world you don't
really know where that is right every
every collection of cell has to figure
that out from scratch
and the fact that Evolution requires all
of these things to figure out what they
are what effectors they have what
sensors they have where does it make
sense to draw a boundary between me and
the outside world the fact that you have
to build all that from scratch this
autopoiesis is what defines uh the
border of a self now biology uses like a
um a multi a multi-scale competency
architecture meaning that every level
has goals so so molecular networks have
goals cells have goals tissues organs
colonies uh and and it's the interplay
of all of those that uh that enable
biology to solve problems in new ways
for example in xenobots and various
other things
um this is
you know uh it's it's exactly as you
said in many ways the cells are
discovering new ways of being but at the
same time Evolution certainly shapes all
this so so evolution is very good at
this agential bioengineering right when
evolution is uh discovering a new way of
being an animal yet one animal or a
plant or something sometimes it's by
changing the hardware you know protein
changing proteins protein structure and
so on but much of the time it's not by
changing the hardware it's by changing
the signals that the cells give to each
other it's doing what we as Engineers do
which is try to convince the cells to do
various things by using signals
experiences stimuli that's what biology
does it has to because it's not dealing
with a blank slate every time as you
know if you're Evolution and you're
trying to make make a make an organism
you're not dealing with a passive
material that is is fresh and you have
to specify it already wants to do
certain things so the easiest way to do
that search to find whatever is going to
be adaptive is to find the signals that
are going to um convince itself to do
various things right
your senses that Evolution operates both
in the software and the hardware
and it's just easier and more efficient
to operate in the software yes and I
should also say I I don't think the
distinction is sharp in other words I
think it's a Continuum but I think we
can but I think it's a meaningful
distinction where you can make changes
to a particular protein and now the
enzymatic function is different and it
metabolizes differently and whatever and
that will have implications for Fitness
or you can change the huge
um amount of information in the gene
though that isn't structural at all it's
it's uh it's signaling it's when and how
do cells say certain things to each
other and that can have massive changes
as far as how it's going to solve
problems